en este vídeo vamos a dar comienzo a un
tema de estadística muy importante que
es el teorema
central
central del límite
el nombre puede parecer un poco confuso
pero vamos a tratar de trabajar la idea
de una forma que se pueda comprender sin
ningún problema
supongamos que tenemos una distribución
cualquiera de un experimento cualquiera
supongamos que estamos arrojando un dado
tenemos entonces el 1 el 2 el 3 4 5 y 6
y es un dado un tanto extraño ya que
tiene
varias probabilidades de que salga el 1
ninguna probabilidad de que salga el 2
tenemos igual probabilidad de que salga
el 3 y el 4 ninguna probabilidad de que
salga el 5 y grandes probabilidades de
que salga el 6 es decir vamos a tener
también por lo tanto vamos a tener una
media aritmética vamos a tener una
cierta desviación típica
y vamos a tener una distribución de esta
forma que pocos se acerca a una
distribución normal fíjense entonces
vamos a aclarar más esto para que se vea
bien
fíjense de que pocos se acerca a lo que
sería una distribución normal esto si lo
queremos
graficar de esa forma estaríamos viendo
algo semejante a esto o sea nada que ver
a una distribución normal pero lo que
dice el teorema central del límite es lo
siguiente no les voy a adelantar nada
preferible trabajar esto de la siguiente
manera supongamos que tomamos una
muestra de estos de este dado arrojamos
un dado no sé una cantidad de veces
decimos que el tamaño de la muestra
es decir la cantidad de veces que vamos
a arrojar el dado va a ser 4 es decir
vamos a arrojar el dado cuatro veces
tantas veces sea necesario es decir
estaríamos haciendo muchos experimentos
que consisten en tirar el dado cuatro
veces se comprende la idea es decir
vamos a tener una muestra 1 una muestra
2 una muestra 3 una muestra 4 así
sucesivamente hasta llegar a una muestra
n que no la conocemos no usemos n porque
ya lo usamos una muestra m que no
conocemos cuál es pero sabemos que en
cada uno de estos experimentos de estas
muestras vamos a tener cuatro tiros del
dado ahora bien trabajamos un poco con
estas muestras supongamos que una de
esas muestras vamos a bajar supongamos
que la muestra 1
nos arroja un 1 otro 11 3 y un 6
es decir que si ahora nosotros queremos
averiguar la media aritmética de esta
muestra decir el x barra
1 hacemos 1 123 5 + 6 11 y 11 / 4 es
2,75
supongamos otra muestra nos muestra 2 en
la que sale el 3 el 4 el 3 y el 1 100 se
que nunca va a poder salir ni el 2005 y
que la probabilidad de que salga el 1 y
el 6 son bastante altas entonces bajemos
acá y sigamos con esto
sale un 314 otro 32 y un 1 por lo tanto
la media de esta muestra en este caso va
a ser 336 más 410 más 111 dividido 4
otra vez 275 veamos otra muestra más
esto lo podemos hacer todo todo el
tiempo que querramos pero el vídeo sería
muy largo vamos a hacer una última
muestra con 2 1 y 2 6
cuya media aritmética nos va a dar que
es 35
por lo tanto nosotros podemos hacer
todas las muestras que querramos hasta
llegar a mil mil diez mil cien mil la
cantidad que sea sin embargo estos no
tienen sentido porque no es cuestión de
inventar muestras lo que les quiero
comentar acerca del teorema central del
límite es lo siguiente
veamos estas estas muestras como
quedarían expresadas en una
en una tabla de frecuencia de
frecuencias entonces tenemos el 275
vamos a tener acá el 2 supongamos vamos
a tener acá el 3
vamos a tener acá el 35
y veamos el 275 apareció dos veces
en cambio el 35 apareció una vez
la idea de esto del teorema central del
límite es que a medida que nosotros
vayamos agregando
muestras
así hasta llegar a la muestra
supongamos acá vamos a ir agregando
distintas distintos bloques por así
decirlo que siempre van a atender
a demostrarnos que tenemos
una distribución normalizada
una distribución normal
veamos de otra manera permítanme borrar
acá
veamos lo siguiente
supongamos que tenemos
tenemos el 2 tenemos el 3
tenemos el 4 acá va a estar el 275 acá
va a estar el 35 y supongamos que cada
una de las de las de las medias de la
muestra nos determine un punto teníamos
dos puntos saca un punto acá y si
seguimos intentando una cantidad
infinita de veces por así decirlo o una
gran cantidad de alta de muestras
siempre con n igual a 4 vamos a obtener
algo si seguimos agregando puntos algo
muy semejante
a lo que sería una distribución normal
obtendríamos algo semejante a esto pido
perdón por los puntos pero quiero que se
entienda el concepto cada uno de estos
puntos sería un una vez que nos salió
determinado valor en la media de la
muestra es decir cada punto
1x barra psuv y verdad entonces
esto para n igual a 4 insisto ahora si
nosotros en vez de usar n igual a 4
usamos por ejemplo n igual a 20 y
hacerlo con otro color
en igual a 20 lo que sucedería sería lo
siguiente acá tenemos claro está una
media vamos a marcarla
tenemos
una media y una media de la muestra
verdad
entonces si nosotros hacemos con n igual
a 20 obtendríamos
algo diferente
pero similar es decir tendríamos la
misma media el mismo
valor medio
pero tendríamos un desvío típico más
pequeño
fíjense que mientras tenemos en verde
esto acá
esta vaca tendríamos en amarillo esto
acá
por lo tanto no solo a medida que la
cantidad de experimentos que realizamos
si la cantidad experimento que
realizamos tiende a infinito esto me va
acercando a una recta a una distribución
normal sino que a medida que el tamaño
de la muestra aumenta
esto se vaya acercando cada vez más a
una distribución normal perfecta es
decir entonces
si el tamaño
desde la muestra
tiende a infinito claro que nunca vamos
a estar haciendo infinitas infinitos
intentos sino que esto va a tender a
infinito va a ser un número muy alto a
medida que esto sea un número más alto
vamos a obtener una distribución normal
y esto es un concepto muy importante si
tenemos en cuenta que partimos de una
distribución que no era para nada normal
esta es una distribución cualquiera
que al realizarles las muestras y este
trabajo con el teorema central del
límite llegamos a que mientras el tamaño
de la muestra se acerque a infinito o
sea un número cada vez más alto vamos a
obtener una distribución normal en los
siguientes vídeos vamos a seguir
trabajando con esto les recomiendo que
los vean vamos a profundizar mucho más
en el tema que es un concepto muy
importante